I am not informed enough to talk about it in a meaningful.
You cannot keep using I'm not informed
as a reason to not speak out about a genocide
seven months into it.
If October 2023, last year.
Look, um,
I'm not informed. Okay?
Take. Take a week,
a couple of days,
a couple of weeks to inform yourself.
Seven months. We're in may of 2024.
When you platform of hundreds of thousands,
millions, or multiple millions of people,
you do not have the ability and privilege to say, um,
I'm not educated,
I'm not informed.
I can't talk about, because at the very least,
if you yourself do not have the language or capacity,
which I disagree with.
I think that everyone has the capacity to inform themselves
if they so choose.
There are countless of educators
who have come online to explain the issue in the most simplest terms
that even anyone with a small,
little, tiny,
tiny brain could understand.
You are more than capable of educating yourself.
And this I'm just a little comedian act,
it does not. I don't know what you're doing.
But even if.
Even if you were so unintelligent and unable to communicate a thought,
which, again, you are not,
you are more than able to share and amplify the voices
of people who are smarter and more educated on the topic than you.
Even when I'm at a place where I don't know what there is left to say,
there are still People saying things that need to be amplified.
And what is the point of having a platform if you cannot,
at the very least,
lend that platform to the people that are doing, educating,
that are doing the work,
that are doing the things to help those that are suffering right now?
I hate this little oh,
I'm so weak and I'm so uneducated and I'm so stupid routine.
No, you are not.
Stop infantilizing yourself
and educate yourself on something that is happening right now
in the world, is affecting tens of thousands of people.
Be an adult and learn about the world.
God, it's pathetic.